herpes heilt krebs belastender lärm und
atmet das sind nur drei der fünf themen
heute den klicksafe news der vw skandal
war in den letzten wochen das thema in
den nachrichten der großkonzern
volkswagen hat bei den diesel emissions-
zahlen betrogen
genauer gesagt sie haben eine software
installiert die bei offiziellen tests
die mission niedrig gehalten hat jetzt
haben wissenschaftler in den
environmental research letters eine zahl
veröffentlicht die keine emissionswerte
sondern tote nennt den forschern zufolge
hätte der betrug 60 amerikanern das
leben gekostet
diese zahl ist eine statistische und
nicht reale zahl
das heißt die zahl basiert auf
berechnungen und nicht auf anfassen
beweisen wie soll man auch nachweisen
dass jemand genau an diesen abgasen
gestorben ist die zahlen statistisch
aber sie scheint dennoch aussagekräftig
genug zu sein zitat ich würde mich nicht
wundern wenn unsere zahlen vor gericht
auftauchen so stephen berit vom
massachusetts institute of technology
kurz mrt
neben ihm haben auch noch forscher der
harvard university
bei den berechnungen mitgeholfen bleiben
wir mal bei den missionen zitat es ist
kaum zu glauben aber wahr die 15 größten
seeschiffe der welt stoßen jährlich mehr
schädliche schwefeloxide aus als alle
760 millionen autos weltweit
und kein einziges der luxuriösen
kreuzfahrtschiffe die jetzt mit großen
fanfaren in hamburg einlaufen würden die
abgasnormen schaffen die für autos oder
lastwagen schon lange gelten so der
landesvorsitzende des nabu hamburg
alexander porschke
das muss man sich mal vorstellen in der
automobilindustrie kämpft man gegen hohe
emissionswerte und in der schifffahrt
hatte jemand irgend jemand vergessen
scheint suche in einer studie von
professor dr
james corbett ist sogar die rede von
60.000 toten
diese würden jährlich durch diese enorme
emissionsbelastung der schiffe sterben
muss ihren damen appelliert
folgendermaßen an die unternehmen zitat
wir wollen endlich wirksame maßnahmen
sehen dafür müssen die
kreuzfahrtunternehmen ihren kurs ändern
indem sie endlich auf die verbrennung
des sondermülls schweröl verzichten und
auf schiffsdiesel umsteigen
zitat ende hoffen wir dass die
reedereien der automobilindustrie folgen
um umweltfreundlichere schiffe
einzusetzen bzw zu entwickeln denn was
nützen uns die sauberen autos wenn die
schiffe weiterhin den dreck in die stadt
bringen per post gehört zum mit einer
der unangenehmsten hautunreinheiten die
suchen so unangenehm und so schlecht der
ruf von herpes ist so nützlich könnte
herpes tatsächlich in der
krebsbekämpfung sein
bitte was ja tatsächlich das ist noch
nicht mehr so verwunderlich herbst ist
nämlich ein virus und tumorzellen wie
die krebszellen gehören zu den sagen wir
mal priorisierten zellen der viren in
den tumorzellen angekommen verhalten
sich virus zellen ähnlich wie
tumorzellen sie vermehren sich
schlagartig und rotten die tumorzellen
aus tumorzellen werden also von virus
zellen übernommen
das klingt jetzt nicht so vorteilhaft
ist es aber denn forscher haben ganz
spezielle virus zellen darauf
spezialisiert der herpes simplex virus
wurde nämlich einer erkrankung also
nicht einer sondern seiner bekannten
erkrankung beraubt und dient somit nur
noch als tumor killer in amerika ist
diese therapie von der amerikanischen
arzneimittelbehörde fda genehmigt worden
in europa wird gerade noch darüber
verhandelt
suri atmet 67 ps courier of jesse may co
bzw kurz juli genannt ist ein komet der
immer wieder für aufregung bzw
überraschungen gesorgt hat erstmal groß
befand sich in einer sehr besonderen
lage denn tourismus damals so stark dass
er in einer sekunde teilweise über 100
kilogramm material in das all stieß
forscher erhofften sich dadurch ein
besondere materialien zu entdecken
beziehungsweise an diese überhaupt erst
zu gelangen und jetzt scheint es ihnen
gelungen zu sein wissenschaftler der
universität bern haben in der
fachzeitschrift nature einen
spektakulären fund vermeldet zitat das
ist der überraschendste fund der uns
bisher bei 67 p gelungenes zu katrin alt
weg und objekt ist nichts geringeres als
sauerstoff im inneren des kometen suri
würde sich sauerstoff in form von eis
befinden also sauerstoff haltiges
sozusagen sauerstoff wurde bis dato
tatsächlich noch nie in der nähe von
kometen gefunden aber eben bis dato
bis dato waren auch die folgen von
verkehrslärm noch nicht so umfassend
untersucht wie jetzt forscher haben mit
ihrer jura studieren noch mal eine
ordentliche schippe
ein bisschen drauf gelegt nur a steht
für neues related ereignissen und half
im zuge der nora studie sind die
experten auch folgende resultate
gekommen
depressionen entstehen häufiger aufgrund
von fluglärm als aufgrund von
straßenlärm herz und kreislauf
erkrankungen treten besonders häufig bei
einer durch züge oder ähnliches
bedingten lärmbelastung auf vor einem
jahr also vor rund einem jahr
berichteten die forscher in ihrer
teilstudie sogar von kindern aus dem
rhein main gebiet die schleppender lesen
lernten als kinder die nicht unter einer
fluglärmbelastung standen zitat ich muss
weniger angst vor einem herzinfarkt
haben aber ich sollte mir darüber klar
sein dass fluglärm eine starke
psychische belastung darstellt so rainer
guski von der bochumer ruhr-universität
den betroffenen anwohnern muss man sowas
wohl wirklich nicht mehr erklären
für gesetzliche regulierungen könnte
eine solche studie doch aber bestimmt
hilfreich sein oder eben so nicht mehr
erklären muss man dass uns das
fortlaufende bienensterben echt heftig
treffen wird mit welcher methode
experten jetzt da gegensteuern wollen
beziehungsweise schon dabei sind dagegen
zu steuern
erfahrt ihr im video hier oben unter dem
dach von block kommt ihr auch über das i
und lasst uns mal ein bisschen
diskutieren bisschen erfahrungen
austauschen
wie seht ihr das mit dem fluglärm wohnt
hier in einem betroffenen gebiet bzw
kennt ihr jemanden der dort wohnt lass
uns noch mal überlegen was könnten für
gegenmaßnahmen in betracht kommen gibt
es irgendwas was da sinnvoll wäre
lasst es uns in den kommentaren
diskutieren haben schon gesagt und das
dann wünsche ich noch ein schönes
wochenende und einen guten start in die
nächste woche und bis 1